this is a forward three BP and a lot of
people really like the feeling of this
when they learn it that's kind of like a
you know a great kind of milestone to
reach and it's called the three beat
we've for a think about it a couple
reasons if you look how it passes my
left foot and my right foot you can see
there's three boom boom boom boom boom
boom
three down swings on each side one two
three one two three one two three one
two three one two three one two three
that's I think how most people think of
it as being the three beat weave you can
also count three circles of that each
hand makes and that would look like this
one two three one two three one two
three one two three so the right hand
makes two circles in the left side and
one circle on the right side the left
hand makes two circles on the right side
one circle on the left side and those
circles all weave around each other
making a complex criss cross C pattern
with one two three one two three so I
can think of the three beats I can think
of a one hand give a three beats it's
making or I can look at either side and
go pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow
pow pop top to learn it we're gonna pay
a lot more attention to the one two
three one two three and thus to
fundamentally important lead-ups that
will take us into the three beat weave
and we start with one of them so
grabovoi great in your right hand face
this way with me
and start just going one two three one
two three two circles on the left side
only one struck on the right side to
reset reset one two three one two three
one two three and start committing to
this rhythm three one
two three one two three one two three
but your other arm will be involved so I
think it's really slow hold your right
arm out kind of in like in front of your
sternum so your left arm your your right
boys gonna go one right so that's this
is touching the bottom then let your
left arm swing to the left so when you
make an second circle to and come back
you're now under your left arm you can
finish that so I could come back to this
side that's three and your left arms
you're kind of in front of your right
shoulder so you can go one two three one
two three are you learning to speed that
up one two three one two three one two
three but I want you to start slow
because a lot of people think they need
to go like this one two three
what and then they skip learning
something really important so the really
important thing is if you go to one you
can be way up at your elbow as long as
you drift out the second circle will be
under you don't have to pull your arm
back then you go three so you trust me
this is gonna work 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
over under over under over under if
you're not sure you can just go like
this make circles your hip my right
hands over mixture over and then after
the pipe passes your hand just go out
here and you'll be under try it yeah but
don't pull back yeah overcome my fear so
you're over and you go pull and then
you're under like this
over/under yeah it's amazing what it
works over and I think me up at my
shoulder over thunder so you need that
pattern over under back over under back
1 2 3 1 2 3 and you need to equally
comfortable in each hand simply with the
right hand and again you can start
really slow you can go 1 2 3
over under back over and under and back
over and under and back over and under
back 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 3 1 and the
hand that doesn't have a point let it
start to be really loose everything
what kind of bob and weave so really let
your body turn really breathe completely
relax everything kind of follows your
sternum when you feel that you're moving
and each hand grooves equally you're
ready to proceed
[Music]